hi I'm Megan from Khan Academy and in
this video we'll learn how to find an
assign exercises videos and articles on
Khan Academy for your classes or
students
in order to create an assignment we
recommend teachers start by finding and
assigning content right from the
assignments tab on the teacher dashboard
from the teacher dashboard select one of
your classes and then click on
assignments on the left side navigation
to expand all of the options under
assignments and then click assign now
select your preferred course from the
drop-down menu and you will see the full
content for the course divided into
units units are organized into lessons
which in turn contain videos articles
and exercises courses that are already
aligned with the common core and ap show
the standards tagged to each unit lesson
video article and exercise by clicking a
piece of content you can view the
exercise watch the video or read the
article before assigning it to students
in addition hovering the cursor over a
code shows the text of that Common Core
standard when you find what you need
check the boxes for individual pieces of
content or the entire lesson and then
click assign while it may seem appealing
to assign an entire unit to a class we
don't recommend this when you assign a
unit to a class each item appears as a
separate assignment to students which
means you could be giving students 20 30
or even 60 assignments whenever you
assign a piece of content you need to
choose the class or classes students due
date and time of the assignments you can
assign to a specific class a few classes
or all of your classes at once you can
still assign for one student a group of
students or all of your students there
is also an option for teachers to select
the content they wish to assign but save
the assignment for some time in the
future you can click assign to send the
assignment to
students immediately or click Save and a
sign later to save the assignments for
later time in addition for exercises you
can decide whether students will receive
the same question in the same order or a
set of questions selected at random from
that exercises item Bank one note you
can always view the complete item Bank
for an exercise by clicking the exercise
name teachers shared that viewing the
item Bank before creating an assignment
helps them ensure they are providing the
right questions and helps them flag any
concerns before assigning the content to
students in the case of classroom
practice the most common option is to
ask students to work on the same set of
questions this allows you to quickly
identify common mistakes which
highlights areas for reteaching
or allows you to quickly identify common
areas of success to provide
opportunities for celebration if you are
using assignments for independent
practice or homework many teachers
prefer students to work on different
questions in these situations students
are given a consistent number variety
and rigor of questions but because the
questions are not identical students are
encouraged to work independently another
way to make assignments is through the
skills report the skills report shows
the level of skill mastery for every
skill for every student which makes it a
valuable tool for assigning content that
meets the needs of each student select
the unit to expand the report and view
all of the skills within the unit by
hovering over the purple bar to the
right of the skill name you can get a
quick view of the number of students at
each skill level by clicking on the
skill name you can expand the view of
the skill to see which students in the
class are currently at each skill level
you can then use the assign this skill
button on the right hand side to assign
the skill to an individual student group
of students or all students
the same pop-up that appears in the
assignment tab will appear here you can
preview the types of questions that are
included in this exercise by hovering
over the blue view exercise link
clicking on the link will take you to
the student view of the same exercise
many teachers suggest using this report
to sign skills to students at the not
started or attempted levels to encourage
them to increase their practice time on
that skill another way to make
assignments on Khan Academy is through
the tool bar when you browse any content
on Khan Academy from the student
perspective as long as you are logged
into your teacher account the tool bar
will appear at the top of the page you
can use the toolbar to make assignments
using the same information you would
from the assignments tab or skills
report one other thing you can also find
the content you need by using the search
bar you can search by subject concept or
even by standard Common Core State
Standards for K through 12 math or AP
standards for our AP courses you can
then filter the results by videos
articles exercises and more when you
find the content you want click on the
item and use the toolbar to complete the
assignment options if you ever need to
edit or delete an assignment use the
manage tab under assignments now that
you have an idea of how to create
assignments a question we hear a lot is
what does this look like for students
students will find assignments on their
learner home page the page they see as
soon as they log in under the
assignments tab for each class students
will see all of their active assignments
past assignments and the due dates for
completing each assignment assignments
are organized by due date with the
soonest due date at the top
as students complete their assignments
and work on each question they receive
instant feedback on how they are doing
and both you and the student received
data on their performance almost
instantaneously students are unable to
make several attempts to complete the
assignments and we encourage students to
learn from their own mistakes if you
assign different questions for each
student they will receive a new set of
questions selected at random on each
attempt and just as a reminder students
can also view and complete assignments
for any class in the Khan Academy mobile
app we know this is a lot of information
to take in and we hope this helps you as
teachers to create assignments for your
students on Khan Academy some concepts
work particularly well for classroom
practice choose concepts that are more
difficult or that can generate good
discussions and debates and start slowly
by creating just a few assignments to do
in a class most teachers recommend three
to five assignments per week gradually
you will build up a routine of using
Khan Academy that best meets the pace of
your students we hope this video helps
you get started creating assignments for
your students on Khan Academy